哈喽,大家好,我是乌鸦太太
你们这周过得好吗?
不知道你们有没有这个感觉
今年好像时间过得特别快
一转眼就只剩下三分之一了
最近虽然因为我自己的行程紧凑
比较少发Instagram
不过本周会有赠书活动
如果有想参加的人
可以来关注看看哦
之前有看过我的影片的朋友
应该都知道
手冲咖啡对我来说
是现在几乎每天都会做的事
其实之前我大部分是使用咖啡机的
早上起来喝咖啡
虽然是长久以来的习惯
但自从开始练习手冲
除了饮用
感觉跟咖啡的连结跟喜好
好像有了更深一层的理解
今天也收到King Grinder的邀请
想跟大家来分享
我这个手冲新手将近一年以来
使用的一些用具
还有我的使用心得
如果对于手冲咖啡有兴趣的朋友
或是想知道我如何选择
我的滤杯或工具的
就一起跟我来看看吧
我的简单生活练习
我的手冲咖啡道具
不知道你们有没有手冲咖啡的习惯
我想先跟大家简单说明一下必备的工具有哪些
首先是手冲壶
主要是用来注水
而使用上是否顺手是我最大的考量
再来是磨豆机
主要分成电动跟手磨两种类型
不同粗细的咖啡粉会很大的影响我们冲煮咖啡的风味
所以能均匀的将咖啡豆磨成粉状还蛮重要的
再来是手冲过程中变化性最大的滤杯
各种形状跟材质的滤杯都会影响到我们的手冲风味
而不同的滤杯也会对应到不同的滤纸
当然现在也有棉布或是网状等不需要滤纸的过滤方式
最后是一些使用的配件
也就是承接咖啡的下壶
即时秤跟豆池
这个部分只要选择自己喜欢的外观跟使用顺手度就可以了
我的手冲壶之前在上半年爱用品的影片中已经介绍过了我也把影片连结放在上方有兴趣的人也可以看看之前的影片一开始因为不想购买太多用具
所以选择了手冲跟加热壶二合一的百慕达热水壶
使用下来觉得除了外观好看
加热速度快
气口壶的出水很稳定
也对我在练习控制注水力度蛮有帮助的
不过因为容量只有600ml
所以如果是多人家庭或是热水使用频率高的人
可能也要考虑一下容量
再来是磨豆机
一开始我也考虑过需不需要购买电动的磨豆机
不过因为比较占空间
所以先使用朋友闲置的便锡型手摇磨豆机
尺寸小小的方便携带
但是一次差不多只能磨出一人份的咖啡豆比较麻烦
也因为刀盘材质的关系
磨出来的咖啡粉粗细比较不均匀
刀盘不够力的磨豆机
也不能磨成适合做意识咖啡的细粉
所以后来我也开始物色
可以两用的手摇磨豆机
目前我使用的是King Rider的K4磨豆机
之前有看过影片的人
应该都对它的身影不陌生
这九个月的时间
我每天都是使用这一台
一开始单纯觉得它简洁的外观
与适合使用的场景
很符合我的需求
收到的当下最大的感受是锥形的木质手把
拨起来很舒适外手感也很好
机身是金属材质的比较沉
拿起来也很有质感
一次磨豆大约可以放进30克左右的咖啡豆
做两人份的咖啡刚刚好
使用了一阵子后
我自己最喜欢的部分是上调式的刻度显示方式
对于新手来说这个显示方式很直觉
一圈有60格刻度加上4圈的深度
可以做240格的细微调整
再来是旋转的力举够长
因为我的力气蛮小的
而这台就算是我
也可以轻松研磨硬度较高的浅焙咖啡豆
这次受到King Grinder的邀请
要来体验等级更高的K6磨豆机
这两台主要的区别是在于刀盘的设计
K4的刀盘是六角的镀钛刀
适合研磨中深焙的咖啡豆
用来做一式咖啡可以凸显豆子的甜味
K-6的刀盘是七角钢刀可以很好的表现咖啡明亮的香味与酸味更适合喜欢浅焙手冲咖啡的我目前体验下来
使用我最熟悉的冲煮方式
设定同样的研磨粗细下
一次冲煮了两种不同烘焙程度的咖啡豆
适合后我觉得K6更适合喜欢单品中浅焙咖啡豆的人
比起之前使用的K4更能呈现豆子不同的香气
喝起来的口感也更清爽明亮
而喜欢口味醇厚的中生焙咖啡的人
可以四抹出来的咖啡粉
因为凸显了咖啡中的甜味
也会让中生焙咖啡中的苦涩味不那么明显
陪我一起试喝的老公也觉得很神奇
不同的刀盘竟然也会让咖啡的香气与风味
有不一样的充足成果
再来是滤杯
目前我有两个分离式滤杯
还有一个CAMX的一体式咖啡壶
CAMX这个一体式咖啡壶
我使用的是全玻璃的三人份版本
也是我最常使用的咖啡壶
这个咖啡壶我大约是三四年前购买的
当初是因为喜欢它的造型跟方便性而购买的
目前我也对于它的冲煮方式在习惯
不过长久使用下来
目前滤杯的边缘有一点裂痕
如果有找到更喜欢的款式
可能会考虑更换
这个咖啡壶上方是锥形的滤杯设计
流速比较快
冲煮出来的咖啡香气很足
喝起来口感也比较清爽
搭配浅焙的单品咖啡豆
可以很好的凸显不同的风味
再来是这个Kalita的扇形滤杯
扇形滤杯的流速相对锥形滤杯比较慢一些
冲煮出来的咖啡口味比较醇厚
适合搭配牛奶做成拿铁
煥入手的是小的尺寸
比较适合单人使用
因为老公通常是喝黑咖啡
但我喜欢加牛奶做成拿铁
这个滤杯通常我做自己要喝的一人份咖啡的时候会使用
最后是这个金属的网状滤杯
这个滤杯跟之前的几个不太一样
不需要用滤纸
单纯透过金属网来过滤
好处是因为没有透过滤纸或是布来过滤
所以冲煮的时候咖啡油不会被吸收
喝起来口味最重
如果想充足加大量冰块的冰咖啡的时候很适合我想做咖啡冰块的时候也会使用这个外出露营或登山等携带也很方便除了轻巧挖也不易破损
不过因为咖啡滤网的过滤方式
如果咖啡粉的研磨粗细不均
比较会有细粉沉淀的问题
当然除了滤杯基本的形状外
各种材质跟品牌的设计
也会呈现出不同的充足效果
而这也是我觉得手冲咖啡最好玩的部分
同样的咖啡豆透过不同的冲煮手法
咖啡豆的研磨粗细
还有滤杯的流速等
可以尝试跟变化出很多不一样的风味
最后是一些咖啡冲煮配件
首先是咖啡下壶
除了刚刚提到的一体式K-MAX咖啡壶外
其他的两个滤杯都可以搭配这个卡丽塔的咖啡下壶
我自己对于承接的下壶没有太多的讲究
主要以简单干净的外观
加上使用顺手就可以了
可莉塔咖啡壶
纯玻璃的款式
就很符合我的需求
再来是一个有计时功能的厨房秤
主要是用来测量咖啡豆的重量
手冲时候的水量
还有计算每次冲煮的时间
我的这个厨房秤
是朋友家里闲置的赠品
不过我自己觉得它没有很精准
如果未来看到适合的品项
可能会考虑替换
最后是这个定量的咖啡豆池
手边没有厨房称的时候
可以大概量出需要的豆量
不过因为浅焙跟深焙的咖啡豆重量不太一样
所以比较不适合喜欢很精准计算咖啡克树的冲煮方式
以上就是这周想跟大家分享
我目前拥有的一些手冲咖啡器具
透过滤杯的选择与不同的冲煮方式
调整咖啡豆研磨的粗细
搭配上各种产地的咖啡豆
每天的手冲咖啡
也成为我早上最期待的行程之一
手磨咖啡豆跟冲煮时散发的咖啡香
也成为我家早上定番的早晨香气
对我来说除了可以唤醒我的早晨
也是在家让我感到很安心的一种存在
你们在家最喜欢的行程是什么呢
有没有什么让你特别着迷的小事呢
如果你愿意
也欢迎留言跟我分享哦
希望你们喜欢我的简单生活练习